let's go to the phones at 617-830-4750
let's go first today to ronald reagan
who has been trying to get on for a very
very long time
and uh ronald what's going on today
well i don't know i don't know about
your framing i'm
trying to get on for a very long time i
mean i guess kind of but well you've
been sending me tweets saying
i've been calling in i've been calling
in sort of stuff
well i wish you would follow me back
david i want to be friends with you
that's the thing but
oh okay so i've got a couple couple
questions for you
um you announced the big
race to a million subscribers on your
youtube
with the majority report um so that's
completely that that so that was
at the time you asserted hold on a
second ronald
at the time you asserted that i had not
done that
i have since been pushed into a war
because sam fired a shot across the bow
saying that i was using bots
sure sure i mean i feel like it was
implied
i mean one does not race against himself
so i mean it's a race against the clock
okay um at the time
you guys were pretty close and now
you're you're really pulling away which
you deserve
tremendous credit for really and i
wonder do you think it's
yeah i mean you're at 917 and
and the majority reports at 9 10. i mean
they're
really struggling to keep up do you
think it's a stamina issue
for sam cedar oh wait what tell me what
you mean by that
well i mean you're just you're churning
out the content
i mean you can't be stopped you're
you're a literal
content machine and he kind of comes on
and does his
one little show per day and sometimes he
has to
have his producers host the show so he's
not even really he's kind of phoning it
in some of the time
well listen the thing is sam is doing
more content than me most days
like sam does a three-hour show i do a
one-hour show so i think that what
you're saying is empirically wrong
oh okay yeah um
so you don't think it's a stamina issue
for sam then i have no evidence that
sam's lacking in stamina
okay so what do you think it is i mean
that you're you're just
uh you know really pulling away here it
doesn't even seem
it's hard to hardly call it even a race
anymore
i am not going to necessarily indulge
your characterization
and i don't know what's going on i mean
in my experience you know
we've had times where we'll get like 8
000 new subscribers in a month and i'm
just doing
the same thing i'm doing my show every
weekday and then we'll have a month like
july
where we get 39 000 subscribers in a
month and
i'm not doing anything different i mean
i think what is going on is in general
we're getting closer to the election
more people are interested but in terms
of any discrepancies between my channel
and other channels
i don't know what it is i think these
things kind of come in waves
david let me ask you a serious question
because um
i really like your show i'm being
sincere
and i like your show a lot um
and so i posted about this and a lot of
people were
were trying to you know dunk on you or
whatever i'm not i'm not here for that
one thing that people were saying or
this came up a bunch of times is that
pacman was wrong about the coup in
bolivia and i don't know anything about
that
i didn't i wasn't paying attention i
guess to what you said at the time
and so i'm curious if you want to
respond to those people
maybe have that kind of to maybe have
that concern i'm being i'm being totally
sincere i'm not trying to like start
uh something but i'm curious um what
that's all about
you'd have to ask them they i guess
they'd have to call in and tell me
specifically what it is they want me to
say or or whatever um if they're acting
in good faith
i'm glad to talk to them and you know as
i'm sure you know
many people in this space don't act in
good faith
and if that's the case i mean i would
tell them to call in because you're not
if you if you have a specific question i
could answer it but to say
respond to people whose comments i've
not seen and whose
arguments i don't know would be
difficult to do
yeah that's fair enough all right well
i'll tell people
i'll spread the number far and wide
please i would love to see your comment
so i can i can respond directly to it
but
um uh keep up the good work oh but i was
gonna say
it i think that you guys need to hash
out some sort i mean there needs to be
stakes it can't just be somebody get
there and
and then that's it so um
you know i i think the
the payoff should be uh the loser has to
do stuns out guns out
tank top shows for a whole week
you know i don't i don't even um i don't
even own
what i think is sometimes colloquially
and inappropriately described as a wife
beater shirt and i know that that's a
very inappropriate term some people call
it an
a shirt or a male tank top i don't even
own
such a shirt so we'd have to first start
up a collection to even get me such a
shirt
well that's not a problem that can be
arranged good um
all right thanks david okay ronald i
appreciate the phone call wow
wow just a lot a lot happening there
let's go next to our caller from the
seven two zero
area code who's calling today from seven
two zero
hey david that me yeah who's this
hi this is gabriel from colorado gabriel
from colorado what's on your mind today
so i know a little while ago it might
have been like half a year ago or
something at this point
you're asking about how to maybe i think
you're asking the audience for ideas on
how to maybe branch out into the spanish
speaking
sort of content creation area yeah
that was i do remember that and we
basically we
we evaluated all of the possibilities
and decided
i really need to reduce my workload by
about 30
and starting to do another show in
spanish was not going to allow me to do
that so we've
we've sort of gone away from the idea
okay
i did have a sort of low effort low time
commitment idea
okay yeah so so the idea is you record
the show
as normal and then you pick one topic or
one story from the show and just
re-record it in spanish you don't even
edit it you just like a daily
one one like five to ten minute upload
in spanish
i figured that'd be a pretty low effort
way to reach out to a whole new audience
and let me ask you this do i post it to
my english language youtube channel or
do i
create a new channel because there's
sort of it's a catch-22
if i post it to my existing channel
english speakers will be annoyed that
there's spanish content if i post it to
a new channel that channel won't have
any subscribers so nobody will watch it
well i was figuring you could grow your
spanish channel over time for just like
a little side project if it doesn't work
no big deal if it does hey look at you
you know it's not a terrible idea i i
don't i don't think it's a terrible idea
to be perfectly frank
now i'm curious what's your interest in
this are you a spanish speaker or is it
more just an effort to reach out to the
spanish community
spanish speaking community i mean i i am
i am trying to learn spanish i'm kind of
doing a bad job but i just think it'd be
a great way to reach out
okay and honestly i think it'd be fun to
just listen to you talking spanish i
like it when you do it's kind of neat
all right well i think that you're if we
were to do it i think what you're
talking about it's sort of like the push
cart model i learned that
i i paid a lot of money for graduate
school where a teacher said
come up with a way to push cart test any
new business idea before you set up a
restaurant
you get a little food cart and you test
it as sort of the gist and i think
you're bringing up an excellent idea
yeah
yeah sure all the there for your
consideration
all right thank you so much i appreciate
it thank you we'll talk to you very very
soon that's
it really is an interesting way to
consider doing it we should look at that